hello good morning good afternoon good
evening whatever the hell you are around
the world welcome to Sidetrack live your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel I'm here
with no that way stormy bear look at
stormy bear
and the young one the young Padawan uh
little Harris
howdy howdy little tiny here very
quickly how are we guys
doing well
fantastic let me just do this thing
foreign
so we don't particularly have a topic
today so if anybody's watching if
there's something you want us to talk
about I do have a little bit of a
Stargate update but it's not much
um but I can do that a little bit later
um but anything you guys want to get
into the comments and you want to
suggest for a conversation please do but
in the meantime guys how have you been
and what have you been up to and did you
all both have a good Christmas I should
say that really oh yeah
good happy New Year this is
it's evening for me though so I'm
allowed good for you
I guess along with my dry January cost
how long that lasted
like right Daniel you just don't drink
alcohol for January to try to like get
over Christmas
I had three days
January 4th I was looking at the booze
I'm like
it's quite a lot of boost
that won't last till February it'll go
off so uh so we're just like we got
screw it start drinking again evening
Adam how are you Panther pictures
behind but I'm sure he'll join us Randy
Coleman you're with us hello everybody
get into the comments guys tell us what
you want to talk about this evening but
yeah so one thing I wanted to talk to
you very quickly Harris you won't be
interested in this just me and stormy
I'm watching Prodigy again
stormy right yes I gotta ask you who's
watching that show
kids
no they're not
it's based I've I didn't really I just
watched it and enjoyed it the first time
right
um but then I was watching it again and
I just with the mindset of if a 10 year
old kid watches this show how much of it
would they actually understand
remembering Voyager ended 20 years ago
who's watching that show well I was I
was I would still say kids were I mean
it's written in a way where you know I'm
guessing they're assuming 10 year olds
weren't around 20 years ago
um
but I think you know it's written in a
way where it's a standalone you don't
have to really know hardly anything
about Voyager you know it's just got
some woman with a coffee cup parking out
orders
his new exposition
I was just watching thinking like the
kids don't know who that character is
they don't know that characters they
have no idea why Jane Ray's so stressed
about jakote they've got something I
just want you to one after thinking this
is just so Random I don't know the
bloody hell's going on but it's bloody
good that's it's honestly I had a did a
live video last week with Sean Ferrick
from truck culture and we were chatting
about it and um and I honestly said I
think the animated stuff is way better
than the live action stuff I think I'm
watching produce I've not watched
strange new worlds twice but I'm
watching concert she twice
okay
going the way of Star Wars huh
Trek Gates says doctor games does not
suck it doesn't suck Star Trek
Enterprise is really good it's awesome
yeah I liked Enterprise some of the best
Enterprise and some of the Star Trek
episodes everywhere Enterprise it's just
over anyway let's not start going to
Star Trek
um well no let's do since you brought it
up sunshine let's talk what why do you
think I think Enterprise failed as a
series and I've got a very specific
reason why would you agree
do you think overall it failed or
it was I I I I it was I don't know I
want I don't want to call it a failure I
think it was I still think it was a good
show it did a lot of things
uh that were cool I did some things that
were blase
um
but anything they can at that point in
time anything that could stay on TV for
four seasons was a success I mean if you
look at other shows that were considered
a big ass success only stayed Four
Seasons you know Firefly huge success
one season I didn't even have a season
12 episodes
It's British season it was a British
summer well it had 16 episodes but
actually only 12 ads
so I think that's right yeah I'd love to
see the last four it really worked for
me Enterprise failed because I hate
prequels so all prequels are a nightmare
to begin with generally speaking but for
me it was supposed to tell us how the
Federation became the Federation and it
just didn't
it it got it tripped over those time
Wars and then the zindy conflict which
was related to the time War
so instead of basically
this amazing story where they could tell
us how the Federation became we just got
these confused time stories and timely
windy crap that just confused everybody
um and they have for me about a really
good I really like the Starship Paul was
lovely
um Scott I love Scott Bakula
um I keep saying but cool and I keep
getting the other
um
um and um and and at all at all the
ingredients it just forgot to do the bit
it was supposed to do which was tell us
about the Federation I just forgot
can I interrupt you for a second I'm
just reading the scroll please go and
subscribe to sciworks for more strumming
pastrami it's supposed to take pictures
from me let's all have a sandwich yeah
damn it let me just edit that bad boy
I'll put the other one up but I think
I think the correct fatigue you know it
was you know at that point in time there
were very few selections you know in
terms of watching you had I mean it was
on um
what was it UPN I think it was yeah and
it was there was there wasn't a million
streaming services we have all this
other sci-fi to blend in you know you
can watch today you can watch Star Trek
and then you can go watch Aliens and
watch something else in the Sarah Connor
Chronicles and
here and but back then it was like all
you could watch was mostly Star Trek you
know I do agree with Adam I think there
was a little bit of uh Star Trek fatigue
there
I think we're at risk again I think
we're actually seeing a bit of sci-fi
fatigue at the moment which is possibly
why I was seeing a bit of a fantasies in
increasing in popularity we've seen a
lot more swords I think these things go
in Ebbs and flows
and it seems to me there's a bit of a
because it's not just starters a lot of
Star Trek on the Telly there's a lot of
Star Wars on the Telly and uh and I
think we're seeing that with um
superheroes as well so that's having a
bit of a downward Trend anymore exciting
as it was yeah
I saw uh uh you know yet again I saw the
last night I saw the trailer for
quantumania and it's like
yeah I can see how they've been cool
they could also be cool if it was a
completely different thing that had
nothing to do with emcu you know
and then I was watching her trailer said
you know I really missed Tony Stark
that's a character
kinda really do
well the next Avengers because we're
going to see another series of Avengers
movie soon and it's going to be Scarlet
Witch probably Ant-Man still and the
wasp
um who else is there oh God the other
characters are so boring I can't even
remember any of them are Doctor Strange
will be there Captain Marvel Doctor
Strange
excuse me these are going to be the
Avengers this time and I don't give a
crap
really about any of them I'm like oh
Marvel witnessing you know like Captain
Marvel's dead
his eyes
you have a comment from uh Nomad
overseas Jeffrey Combs was always
brilliant I mean
I lost track of how many characters he
actually played in the entire franchise
Jefferson
12 to 15. yeah it depends on whether you
if it's either five or like 18 or
something depends on how many times you
counted Wayne
yeah but um but yeah no I love that uh
would you just have a question just what
does everybody think about the new
Quantum Leap series
have you guys managed to watch it or not
um I I kind of haven't watched anything
since November I really
when I got back home from
the funeral it was I didn't turn a TV on
for two weeks that's I turned it on for
the first time last night
out there
the zindy appeared in Prodigy today in
the episode I was watching today is
India running oh really oh that's right
yeah yeah yeah I remember that station
thing up there yeah
um I have been watching it I I've
watched it completely legally it's not
on in this country but I've watched it
anyway
um vpns are great
um so I I currently live in Canada by
the way I know I haven't told you guys
this but according to my internet
I live in Canada there's something
non-legal there you know yeah yeah but
um I've actually quite enjoyed
constantly it's not as good as the
original and I I love the original but
then this time they've they've
modernized it and instead of having you
know like it was a monster of the week
it was just like a different story each
week and the how the whole leaping thing
was just a mechanism to have like the
Touched by an Angel type TV show where
he goes in he helps people he wanders
off this time the actual the whole thing
with
the leaping is way more to do with it
like he's got into the machine for a
reason
to save his girlfriend I think her
name's Addison oh I think it's his
girlfriend I forget now I've only
watched it once
um but I haven't started watching the
second part of the season yet but he's
to save us this Addison woman
um so it's there's a bit where there's
an overarching storyline this time and
people kept going shouted woke at it
it's not
it's just a Asian actor that's it other
than that it's fine
um
and yeah that's it really it's it's one
of those shows you watching you go I
will watch that next week and then if
when next week comes if you happen to
watch it it's fine if you don't watch it
you wouldn't really care
it's not like you'd like
I can't wait for the next episode oh my
God serious finale let's get popcorn
it's not it's not like that
okay what are you gonna do
so um what else have you guys been up to
so last night
um I was watching uh Pluto and I was
watching on the classic Who Channel
and I really forgot and I'm sad to say
this I really forgot how great Sylvester
McCoy was as Doctor Who
I mean he had a completely
I mean he he he he really did I mean I
think he he he really played it straight
as the doctor I thought you know
she's kind of a comedic actor actually
to invest myself so the the nice thing I
like about Doctor Who is that
particularly prefer all of the doctors
they always bring something a little bit
different it's a bit like James Bond you
know
the difference between Sean Connery and
oh God I forgotten his name the guy with
the eyebrow they did it after Sean
Connery
anyway
um and then like even Timothy Dalton who
was crap and I can remember his name
um Roger Moore everyone they always they
always played it a little bit
differently and brought a bit of fun to
it
mine my favorite was
um
Davidson
Doctor Who was always David because he
was the Doctor Who when I was like about
10 I think but um semester McCoy was
great and they always brought something
a little bit different which I like that
very much
let's see what the new the new doctor
can bring
well I didn't know that guy was radagast
I like that
get off
throw him off the screen
of course he was right against the brown
I had to IMDb him McCoy I liked it you
had the idea
being British I know him from a million
things that I could never name because
he's just he was before he was Doctor
Who went after his and doctor he was
just in loads of like
the murder mystery that week you know
like our equivalent to like Murder She
Wrote he'd be on that one week then
you'd be on something else the next week
and then you know I mean so with Ian
McKellen in there which makes sense that
he'd go into The Hobbit after the fact
well again Ian mcallen's a great you
know proper thespian actor who's known
for nothing before he was he was um
Gandalf really and we didn't even really
know him over eggs he was an at this
stage actor mostly
uh one thing I always remember him from
was apt pupil
you guys remember apt pupil
turn your phone off you're live in front
of dozens of people for God's sake hold
on just let me
it very well might be
yeah by the way the the notification was
from The Washington Post we calculated
the happiest least stressful jobs in
America did yours make the cut that was
good yes we all want to know what the
least stressful thing in America is
that's all I say it's not my job you
know before we build spaceships
Harris have stressed to you sir
uh extremely stressed and not stressed
at all
chemical induced depends on the hour
but yeah depends on the hour there's
still breakfast time over there but uh
yeah no I get that
um now I looked I'm really looking
forward to the new Doctor Who but I'm
looking forward because David Tennant
was always my favorite so I think the
new Doctor Who's going to be great and
everyone keeps telling me this new guy
is I'm sorry I can't say his name and I
can't remember it anyway
um but everyone Casino has brilliant
factories but I've never seen him in
anything so I'm like
I'm a bit worried about Doctor Who
was the nikooty guy wasn't he like a
stage guy you're in the stage guy
I only really known that using sex
education on Netflix which is apparently
brilliant and I've never watched it
and apparently he's great in it
everybody that I know that have seen
that or has seen it love sex education
I've never watched it myself but
everyone that I've known that has
watched it adores the show so
everybody's very excited over here about
it but I mean I'm like I'm just worried
about Disney spending
because
I was talking about this about Matt I
think Doctor Who has a feel to it you
know and like the crap special effects
and the the limited budget made them be
more character driven and now they're
going to have treble the budget they had
before
and I know why BBC have done it because
you know like as things progress and
things they couldn't get away with
making doctor the way they did anymore
but I'm just a bit worried that
sometimes too much money can spoil the
broth
I know I'm mixing similes there but you
know what I mean I'm a bit I'm a bit
worried about that I think they could
spend too much money on these shows
so that just made me think about
something that's kind of like the
opposite of what we've all been saying
and thinking about Stargate and it's
kind of a similar way where it's a
Sci-Fi show that chose character
development kind of over large grandiose
sci-fi CGI kind of battles and things a
lot
yeah
they expands and then there was the
expanse
I see going in Doctor Who their husband
for a few years but it just wasn't very
good it's just like um
I think uh so check they just asked
about
um Babylon five I did a video on that a
few days ago so it is moving forwards
the anniversary special we still don't
know what that is but apparently it's
done it's just going to be aired so I
can't remember when the anniversary is
off top of my head
I believe isn't it there's a Babylon 5
anniversary special coming in I haven't
heard about it yeah we don't know what
it is though JMS just dropped this um
tweet oh God it's probably six months
ago now
um just saying that it's done the
anniversary special is done it's it's in
the can
so but we've but he never told us
anything else so we have no idea what it
is so it could be anything from some
sort of episode or
cartoon or I think it's more likely it's
going to be some sort of interview
um and then apparently it will be on the
CW at the anniversary and I think that's
I want to say August
but it might be a bit early June July
August sort of time
um do we think the CW will hold out
until August
probably not I'm hoping to put it on HBO
with everything else but it's Warner
Brothers that have made it so but it
might just it could end up just being an
internet thing for a while you know
it doesn't you know matter does it so
um but the like I said in my video a few
days ago the Babylon 5 reboot looked
like it was dead I was actually told my
couple of people what a picture that it
was dead Warner Brothers we're not going
to spend money on it and now it's like
everything's calmed down and everyone
stopped running around going you know
like
that Warner Brothers and like jumping
out of Windows and things and everyone's
calmed down
and now it's apparently back on back on
table
um but they're still arguing about
whether it's going to win the CW or not
um but uh I I I I think this DW is just
going to be reality TV personally but
we'll see
so going back to the comments you know
uh no matter receives I do I do think
that they interfere with JMS as a
crusade I love Crusade that was just
awesome
you know and and there are so many
places where the story could have gone
I heard that they some of those elements
was uh uh revealed in the comic book
series I've never been able to find it
um and also uh
co-claude uh space 1999 reboot that
would be interesting
I've never I say I am I've got getting
the list of episode series they'd like
to do I'm not going to show you my own
space 1999 but um I did hear a room that
it was like looked at for about five
minutes
but it's never been looked back at but
um it might even be British I can't
remember I don't think I've already
watched space Now Blake 7 is the one
that gets banned around occasionally no
that could be rebooted but apparently
go ahead there's been a bunch of
arguments about who owns it apparently
oh I see
it was a Sci-Fi show from like the 70s
and but it's one of those it's one of
those shows that whenever they do like a
top 10 classic sci-fi series it's always
like really high up on the list
um so you know it's one of those uh it's
one of those shows that's properly cult
cult classic and a modern retelling
might be you'd know if you if you Google
it now you'll know it you'll recognize a
few of the ships and things from Blake
seven okay
um because they're they're they're
pretty iconic sort of thing
um
yeah nobody overseas uh there's so many
of the Caster b5s that are gone with
space 99 and Jerry Anderson okay there
you go that's that explains that
um
Jerry Anderson obviously the heated then
did space precincts a few years later
and obviously you know the Muppets
somewhere
excuse me
Diet Coke and
um vodka you shouldn't drink it live I'm
sure it makes you burp
so um
um Blake seven was never Australian is
it Australian it was a joint venture
with though Who's the who was it jointly
done with her Blake
uh I aim but anyway
um
if the BBC on the rights are screwed but
apparently yeah apparently they don't
know who owns the rights and it's a bit
of an argument over that
um one reboot that's probably gonna
happen and I did I told you this I said
about a year ago that Amazon really
wanted to do this and they've just
apparently finished clearing up all the
arguments I'm getting about who owns it
MGM sold loads of it stuffed people
um a remake of a Forbidden Planet is
looks like it's gonna happen they've got
a strict a script that was done by James
Cameron and Jay Michael susinski from
Babylon five Fame there is a script that
was written a couple of years ago James
Cameron wants to do it
um but with he's quite busy at the
moment so um
apparently
according to somebody I spoke to at the
moment the scripture sort of bouncing
around Amazon
and they're trying to executives are
having a look at it and trying to decide
what to do about it
um so
that looks like that's gonna happen
um I think they'll have to rewrite that
script though because I don't think
James Cameron will get involved with it
and they'll they won't want to pick but
let's say I say that James Cameron could
go on his executive producer or
something really easily and not take up
much of his time but it looks like
forbidden planet's gonna happen
and I've been once again one of those
whenever they do like a top 10 Sci-Fi
movies of all time it all it always ends
up top three
it's um it's a very popular you know
sci-fi classic it's like that in space
you know I'm sorry
Space Odyssey and and films that has and
then like the top couple
so is that a film you'd want to see kind
of interesting yeah
I think it's gonna be good I love that
it's a movie first now if you actually
look at the history of um forbidden
planets like first ever movie that
appeared not on Earth
with the echoing somewhere
no my computer beeped at me my usage
time is down 38 and my computer seemed
very worried about that
you're not staring at me enough
stare at me more
I must have tanked somebody's ad
readings or something yeah so you
mentioned 1999 or Space Odyssey 20.
because it I'm guessing you guys have
seen the Barbie trailer
you know I'm trying to avoid it people
keep telling me it's brilliant
it kind of is
I mean it is essentially
um
not exactly shot for shot but it is
very condensed uh bit of uh
2001 Space Odyssey the very beginning of
it there's these little girls in this
like Rocky Grotto and they've got these
dolls and then one kid starts playing
with one doll and smashes another and
continues smashing
and if they throw the doll up and it
propels itself through space and then
you see the credits
now the movie I'm I have no comment
about the damn movie but the trailer was
unique
unique play on 2001. I'm I'm intrigued
by Barbie and I'm like I'm optimistic
about it that's because you live in
Hollywood that's why you're intrigued
about well I'm partially probably but I
Greta Gerwig herself the lady that's
directing it and co-wrote it with her
husband is fantastic but her husbands
know a bombach who I still haven't seen
White Noise this year but
every other film he's ever done I mean
marriage story was his last film before
that that guy's just
on point every time and he helped her
co-write it so with both of their minds
in it
it could be good but it's also a Barbie
movie so I'm there's some trepidation
the people have got to appear in that
movie you think about Ryan Gosling that
that script must be amazing because I'm
sorry but as soon as that appeared on
his desk he must have just gone no and
then no just read a bit well
y'all remember that that's gotta that's
a good point because this film was
supposed to it was like a whole
different cast and crew and I believe an
entirely different script as well
because Greta Gerwig and Noah bombach
that's why I'm like partially excited
because they rewrote it all you know who
was originally supposed to like cast as
Barbie right no Amy
who sir Amy Schumer
that's that that would have been our
Barbie movie and I'm just not a fan of
her type of Comedy or anything like that
that would not that would not have been
a good movie how would that work I mean
like she's great I I love Amy Schumer
and um it was supposed to be like a
modern kind of oh we don't need some
like Super Hyper beautiful person on the
stage to do this we just need someone
normal to go up there and and give and
you know you're not gonna make a Barbie
movie about that it's a joke it's in the
Amy Schumer movie when she gets a bump
to the head and she thinks she's
gorgeous
that's quite funny
well no that wasn't Amy Schumer so that
was that Australian girl
and that's lost loads and loads of
weight so I don't know her name either a
big girl and she took a Bankhead so she
thought she was gorgeous oh she was um
the actress from Pitch Perfect oh Rebel
Wilson
yeah yeah y'all made me think about I
don't remember who the the I don't know
I don't think it's Gwyneth Paltrow in a
fat suit but what's the movie with Jack
Black where he falls in love with
Gwyneth Paltrow and he only sees Gwyneth
Paltrow but it's yeah
[Music]
um I I actually have a little bit of
news about Highlander oh my gosh let's
go spill
well apparently now that um Henry Cavill
has is not doing Superman as soon as
warham is sorted he wants to do
Highlander movie
um and I I genuinely must be a mind
reader because I said Michelle yo should
be in it as like the Sean Connery
character and apparently he was in an
interview a couple of months ago and he
said he would love Michelle yo to be as
the is to do something in it so I'm just
like [ __ ] Yoda if it's like a
Highlander movie
I got so much [ __ ] for suggesting
Michelle yo should be in that movie is
the shotgunnery there's the Ramirez
character but um
I remember arguing at the time and oh
I'm stood through
oh no I'm gone
I'm done oh so anyway while he's getting
his [ __ ] together I just want to pimp
out the Discord server you do join the
Discord server there and and yeah and
and the coolest thing about the Discord
server is there's we talk about there
there's a Minecraft world that we can
all play in
so jump on it please do we're you can
find us on there a lot
building things
Matt's on there always talking to people
and that's good at responding on there
and yeah yeah I mean yeah it's all
mostly Matt's brainchild and he is on it
yes I mean another brainchild of his
that y'all should check out of course is
nine chevrons
yes oh I need to I need to get a little
more involved with that but Matt's been
Matt and Jamie have both been
kicking stuff out knocking it out of the
park don't you think uh-huh this is
pretty great
so I was going to say
um uh uh I took a friend of mine to see
a way of the water yeah yeah it was you
know again this is my third viewing I
think uh again it was excellent but she
had never seen the first film
and I'm going man this is going to be
some heavy lifting you know will she
understand everything and she thoroughly
enjoyed it just loved the [ __ ] out of it
that I remember without ever seeing the
first uh Avatar so then I slipped her a
copy of Avatar and I think she's
watching it today if she can wrestle her
child's PlayStation away from him
is perfect at I guess explaining
everything to
just the degree you needed today you
know but it really doesn't you really to
to understand uh Jake Sully's uh Journey
from why he's so hot about family from
where he came from you know on the
streets in a wheelchair you know if it
ain't raining we ain't training I mean
it makes only had a really
that's a horrific backstory I mean you
know he was you know he was sent to the
armpits of the earth and he was abused
by the military and
you know and I was watching it I watched
that movie again last night uh the
original Avatar and it was like you know
you can't get this with bet Bennett you
can't get this with uh that benefits not
in this economy how many times do we
actually say not in this economy for
anything I mean we say it every year
every every month we say oh not in this
economy I mean it's like a catchphrase
we almost have for the last 30 years not
in this economy we've really never had a
great economy for the middle class in
America and now I'm done ranting because
Jamie is back thank God because I'm out
of [ __ ] to say I think we're just
randomly tuned itself off
and then wouldn't turn back on
you've got one job
one job
what are you talking about
um
yeah all right yes
um it's long in it
long it's three hours three hours
I'm not sure I liked it all that much
really one
I didn't hate it I enjoyed it I watched
it I will probably never watch it again
um and and it was good and it wasn't of
Avatar but wetter it wasn't it there was
a much more there was a lot more story
there
so it wasn't Avatar wetter
um
I'm sorry so the camera's overheating
for all the hot weather here in Canada
um
but um but yeah um
I just thought it was okay
I mean it's not it's not gonna win an
Oscar for a story anytime soon oh it'll
will Oscar for everyone else I wanna
let's be honest it was beautiful I just
found it a bit like
because I'm gonna go and have a Wii and
a poo and make a phone call and do
something else and by the time I get
back you won't have to tell me what
happened because it is so slow
um I'll catch up
they've got a first four hour long movie
to what world goes over nothing that
happened in this movie
but it's supposed to it's serious for
the first 45 minutes or four
so the one thing that way of water
reminded me of it's kind of a blend
there's a little bit of Abyss right a
little bit of Abyss
yeah kind of a lot of Titanic was in
there and
um and and I think at the very heart it
was a Helen Kepler story
you said a Helen Keller story
with Kiri
no not
um
well I say I'm thinking about the long
Helen Keller because the Helen Keller
that I'm thinking of wasn't she in
America
we should talk about like disability
rights remember you know okay okay
I'm in color
the author American Author disability
rights Advocate all right was there a
serial killer called something
because I went to the serial killer yeah
the killer was not a serial killer Jesus
she would have had trouble dude I'm
sorry
okay
um yeah oh no there's a lot of like you
know there's Native Americans what we
did to them was bad we should probably
not do that again there's a lot of that
in this movie yeah and what you did to
them was bad
we have nothing to do with that one as a
British person I'm sitting back at my
high horse going yeah we didn't have him
to do that one
um but it's um we we just did everything
to the rest of the world
um so I I was um in a history lesson the
once and I was talking about the mat
season now by the Nazis were an avid
concentration camps were and I stuck my
hand up and went British invented the
concentration camp and the teacher just
stared at me
because yeah and and they are into South
Africa So speaking of the Nazis a little
bit of the story was kind of Anne
Frankish
yeah
I mean you read a lot more into that
film than I did I mean I'm there just
going and I was going to say that whale
in a minute that whale's going to Free
Willy this in a second and um probably
gonna jump over everybody and then
they'll be fine I think
it was my third viewing so
that'll do it so you can spend your time
thinking I must think about other films
this reminds me of and Frank
and frame
I just said in Frank you just you just
gotta eat a mushroom or two and then go
sit in there for a few hours it's uh
it'll pain change your week up a little
bit it's uh and part of it almost seemed
like a Discovery Channel series you know
or like the under sea world you know but
in 4k
if you mashed everything from on the
history H2 until one thing
that is what Avatar becomes because H2
is all aliens mats is Shark Week
just Ram them together and you've got
Avatar the way I wore
I totally forgot about Shark Week how
can I forget about Shark Week it would
be popular I'm like let's just what are
people watching on the Discovery Channel
and a little bit of Whale Wars if we're
going that direction let's just toss in
some Whale Wars in there and that gold
digging thing that's popular that gold
digger these are all because they're
obviously the humans are there to try to
get but I thought that was the one thing
actually that did annoy me about the way
I washed while we're going to talk about
it then all right so in the first one on
obtaining was what paid for everything
in the second one even though it's not
mentioned at all the whale brain juice
is what pays for everything
what's going to pay for everything in
the third one
well they're going to the fire people so
think something fiery
well also at this point in the third one
won't the people all already have been
kind of moved from Earth to maybe okay
they might not be completely moved from
Earth to Pandora but
can't you hear the people sing singing
this song of angry man
now it's a little bit of a musical if
lots of things are in a mythical though
of all the people are leaving Earth and
going to Pandora
for that sorry is that is that something
to do with like history and things as
well
there's I mean
it's about the Europeans
yeah it's colonialism but it's also a
Jesus story now because Kiri and it was
kind of set up like that prior to it but
so it's like biblical and Colonial all
kind of
melded in a way it's the what's the
thing of what's that um Mel Gibson film
that they gave the Christ
so it's that
Anne Frank
some Titanic some Abyss
yeah I love that you said Titanic
because you all know what he just
announced again right
so the Titanic is being re-released in
theaters
Valentine's Day and it's still one of
the top five highest grossing
International films of all time it was a
damn good movie
it's the only film I've ever it's the
only non-sci-fi film I've ever watched
at the cinema twice and it wasn't
because I had two girlfriends at the
time and they both made me go watch it
I 100 knew about each other
well that's awkward brought them both
yeah
I'm gonna show the guy that's selling me
the tickets are like you were here with
she was reformed
shot me
um
and and do anything it's not really a
romantic movie I mean she 100 saved
herself at the end of that film
she's I mean I'm not saying it's a
metaphor for marriage but it feels like
it I have to be married for a few years
that it's you know it's like right
that's not enough room on this door yeah
there is no there isn't no there's not
goodbye Jack goodbye Jack come on
goodbye Jack I know just like I'm
married now your life is mine I'm fine
no I'm not saying that I'm
very happily married
um
track games anyone everyone remember
Andromeda
that's also another series that
apparently is people have been talking
about trying to get rid of it really
it's just like let's Resurrect The
Commonwealth again yes let's just
resurrect every TV show there's ever
made because we can't think of anything
new to do that's the thing just come on
if we're gonna do an Andromeda how about
uh Mass Effect Andromeda I know that's
not everybody's favorite game out of the
four but come on I'll play it
um I I I I I
honestly I I I've got to stop making
videos about there's this TV show that's
rumored because the amount of rumors I
get and again from credible people that
know about this thing I know about the
Andromeda thing because I happen to know
um I got information from the agent of
the director that was approached so it's
a hundred percent fact that that um Fox
are looking at and they can maybe making
Andromeda
um but they're also making they're more
further along space above and beyond but
I think they just desperately want a
Sci-Fi show for
um
um for Disney plus and Hulu and they're
literally just going in for like
alphabetically and they've gone like
Andromeda
what can we do can we make an Andromeda
series and then they'll just go to the
next one and then until they get to one
that they can actually make
at least literally just alphabetically I
think they're just desperate to do
something and then they'll eventually
get to X-Files and they'll just make
that
no it's apparently it is
um David coffin is aggrieved dealing
with Amazon and David coffney said he'll
only do it if Jillian Anderson agrees
and that's the only thing that stopped
it
oh wow so um so now they're talking
about Harvard
it's just it's just honestly it's just
ridiculous for a while
for content
and it's cheaper to bring I imagine
anyway it's cheaper to bring something
back
than it is to try to get somebody to
think of a new idea
something you already own you don't have
to buy you can just make
a space above and beyond as well which I
actually genuinely think that's probably
where they're going to go everything I
hear is going to be a Spaceball me on
they make
um they actually had five seasons all
mapped out that they never did
so it's the easiest thing in the world
to reboot they've already got five
seasons ready to go they've just got to
write the scripts
they don't need any imagination at all
right yeah makes it kind of lazy and
easy on them
as well
I hear dream is about slides that long
ago I am sliders though is it one of
these that's been rumored on and off for
ages and about 18 months ago
um it was pretty much getting made there
was even there was a director signed on
and everything
um and then
we know what's happened in the last 18
months and it's it's dead now exactly
so but I think that's a good thing
because I think it's too similar to
Quantum Leap
um I think they needed to do one or the
other
and they're Going Quantum Leap so I
think Quantum League probably kills
Slater's reboot
but I think that's a good thing because
I don't think it's that good the first
season was brilliant of slide isn't it
yeah
this house do you know what we're
talking about no idea
I I read a mass effect comment so I
started typing Mass Effect things
oops but real quick I I was requested to
do a Paul ruddism real quick hey James
Bond in America we drive on the right
side of the road
there we go okay
um
looks like we're about to get a James
Bond
last two guys they just go kick between
the last two guys
and uh we're gonna get a James Bond
shortly which one of them's Aaron Taylor
Johnson which is not a name I would have
expected but it is a name that
could do really well with it uh
that's intriguing I can't remember the
other guy's name but I know him is is
the Johnson guy the um chapter the
bicycle mustache from bullet train yeah
curly hair kick ass
Quicksilver yeah we'll say he's the one
and the other fella uh actually or who
yes okay from you okay yeah the last two
guys so just gonna pick
okay interesting comes out a little bit
of a star gang
um ah
yeah Jerry Ryan's signed on to do a show
um so that 709 will not be appearing in
any more Star Trek
um she's appeared she's signing on to a
show which I keep forgetting to read the
article I sent it to myself and I keep
saying I must read the article and I
never do I haven't yet
um it's some show on AMC is that channel
in America yes
he signed up to the um second season of
something I forget what it was
um but she won't be
doing anymore we will not be seeing
seven and nine in any Star Trek anytime
soon
so the rumor about possibly a Titan
series with the mining
I'm not sure
so let's see what happens
um should be a shame I don't like that
um
seven of nine is a great movement so the
Stargate a little bit of a Stargate
update I've got for you before we start
talking about something else oh God just
a second Mark crinkle apparently yeah
there's rumors about lecture tuning as
well
now that was a team show nobody watched
I actually quite liked it but nobody
watched it
um there's like a necromancer character
in it it was a Public's character and
nobody watched it I don't know why they
would even consider bringing it back but
apparently it did
um right
so I'm always up for a remake of uh time
I mean yeah
yeah I think something that was really
good
um
uh
Dark Skies was a study idiot
um was
um it's not a particularly there's not
much happened I've said just before
Christmas that uh Mark Fergus had did
have meetings with Michael Wright he was
supposed to have meetings with Jennifer
Sharpie from Amazon but that meeting
didn't happen was what I was told so he
met with Michael Wright who's the head
of scripted material at MGM That was
supposed to then go into to meet
Jennifer Salk and that was supposed to
sign everything off and they were
supposed to go ahead and we were all
going to hand in hand with Daisy chains
around the next skipping towards a new
star game but they disagreed on a few
bits
a few little bits of updates I've had
apparently
um there is
um
apparently there is a movie script that
has been produced but I cannot say any
more than that but apparently there is a
movie script that's been knocking around
um that they're allowing people to see
to sort of go oh look we've got a movie
script
can't say any more than that though
because I've been told I'm not allowed
to
um there is potentially another actor
that's been approached
um about leading it and but I'll get a
bit more detail on that and I'll let you
know this week who that is but
apparently
the idea being that before they announce
it they want like a lead actor and they
do that loads of shows nowadays and they
do like Warhammer you already know who's
going to star in it you know and they'll
they like to do that so they've got an
actor they want to approach but the main
thing is right there were meetings in
the last week
then but it was all like just the lower
people just sort of like throwing
numbers around and trying to put a
second proposal together so the
negotiations collapsed they're trying to
put a second negotiation and second
proposal together at the moment and then
apparently next week Mark Fergus will be
in LA and there might be meetings again
between him and Michael Wright so we'll
see if it gets away but at the moment
they're still sort of low
apparently chatting
so it's all like so I would like to
spend eight million uh we'd like nine
how about eight point two yeah it was
like nine and uh you know that's that
that's apparently the conversation going
on at the moment does Brad write other
than you know being known for uh
Stargate does he have any other kind of
uh projects in the works do you think
not Stargate related yeah jump onto IMDb
but I don't think he's got particularly
anything I think a lot of his time at
the moment goes on um he writes still
doesn't he and I know he did a project
for he did a movie for Amazon long ago
he did a script call but I don't think
it went anywhere
um
it keeps trying to get Travelers back
and that's not going anywhere
um
I'm not sure he's got particularly
anything on the go at the moment
no on IMDb Pro that lets you know kind
of like what's coming up with their
stuff as well he doesn't have anything
um I think this is a big part of him
saying about how he tweeted not long ago
saying that there's um ageism in
um Hollywood
and he seemed to have a bit of a
a bit of a complain sort of thing
um
I I think it's disgraceful and I said I
know people that talk to Brad I don't
particularly talk to Brad because he
doesn't like me very much
um I irritated him not as much as Joseph
Mosey Joseph malozi really doesn't like
me
um but I I questioned his politics so
that was never a good idea
um never met Your Heroes um but I do
know people who do speak to Brad Wright
all the time and they he have had no
contact with Amazon at all none not even
to tell him that the script he did do
isn't being taken they've not even said
it's you're not you're not doing it
they've said nothing and I think that's
disgusting
um but it happens all the time they're
just now
um
it's just I don't know
I hate that there's no Brad but at the
end of the day I'd rather just have
Stargate and I I
I've always thought I think I'd rather
have somebody new do anyway if I'm
honest but if there's no bread there's
no Brad
um became on as a consultant but
yeah
[Music]
um
it's just
I just I just wish they'd have the
decency to sort of like have a
conversation with them though and I
don't think Brad would lie about it I
think if if he was asked directly he
would either say well I can't talk about
it or he would say or he would tell the
truth if if they said look it's not
gonna happen but you can't talk about
this you know then I think he would just
say I can't talk about it but he says no
there's been no conversations nothing
they've never even they've never put a
handout MGM or Amazon nobody's ever
that's anything and I just think
that's a movie industry it's a bit [ __ ]
but I suppose they act like a business
and if I went for a job and I didn't get
it they don't always let me know that I
haven't got it they just tell the person
as I suppose but I don't know it just
seems a bit unfair to me well we kind of
compared it to how Amazon treated Peter
Jackson and when they did rings of power
because they asked him to oh come come
help us like let's tie some ideas at
each other and they realized they
legally couldn't and they just ghosted
the guy just stopped talking to him
entirely
so it's kind of similar and just it
sucks for both of them good [ __ ]
I am sick of being shot at the messenger
though that I I tell people Brad
Wright's not doing this and they're like
oh you hate Stargate no I don't
there's a reason we're talking about it
yeah exactly
how would you revive Firefly or would
you leave it alone
see now if we knew how to revive Firefly
we'd have it on our screens I think
it's a difficult algae you guys Harris
did you ever even watch Firefly we keep
telling you to I've I've watched a good
chunk of it but I've never finished it
and I never watched Serenity about it's
one of those ones I always meant to
watch and I I think I chose Freaks and
Geeks over that because I was younger
and I was like young James Franco Seth
Rogen and all these cool people I'm in
for that one and I was like that's my
one season show that I'm gonna go back
and watch but
give it another go you've got to get
pushed through the first couple of
episodes to give another go it's it's
worth it honestly
how about you stormy would you would you
revive it would you bring it back if you
could
I don't know
reboot after reboot you know and I I
would just love to have some sort of new
material you know
something new and fresh
I really would it's I mean that's one
reason why it's so jazzed about expanses
because it wasn't some other thing you
know it was its own thing
yeah
I I do agree with you I think I want new
material
but I can I completely understand why
they keep bringing back these old shows
is because you get an immediate
excitement I can I can do a video on
here and I'll talk about how
this is a new show it looks really
interesting blah blah blah and it'll get
a couple thousand views maybe I do a
show saying fireflies getting a reboot
and I'll get 20 000 views because people
are looking for it they search for it
they're interested in it
keep going keep going
I somebody would have been told to
Firefly is that apparently Disney would
love to do a firefly reboot and they
genuinely don't know how
um and they've they've asked for
pictures from lots of different places
and I know
um uh the guy that does Mandalorian John
Favreau even pitched they even talked
about it he was never going to do it
they wanted him to consult and
apparently and I talked to the um
podcast guys on this and they got a
really good sauce on it and I said at
the time that's that's nonsense that's
that's just not true and I've chatted
him since they said no no they're
talking with the sauce and I'm like ah
okay
um but apparently I found out since it
was never to me it was just a consult
because they don't know how to do it
they're like oh should we do a hard
reboot should we do a soft reboot should
we do this and they couldn't figure out
and they're just like that if we do a
hard reboot we'll piss everybody off if
we do a soft reboot we'll piss everybody
off and if we do try to do a hybrid
thing we'll just piss everybody off so
they're like
so they just don't want to touch it I
think it's almost like it's too long
Jamie you sound like uh
Megatron you sound like Optimus Prime
right now
huh
hey there we go
my audio keeps flicking off I mean
what's going on tonight my camera's been
randomly turned itself off and then the
[ __ ] microphone turned itself off
anyway basically what I was told was
they've got to go and said unless Nathan
Fillion can come back
we can't do Firefly so unless Nathan
Fillion decides to come back it's not
gonna happen
one idea I had that you could go back to
the Firefly universe that would be good
and of course everybody would be mad as
hell but you know if you if you just
take the the show and it's root
storyline is just like a soap opera from
Canton
you know the little mud town the Mudders
it's just a soap opera it has none of
the original cast it's just you know a
soap opera about living under the thumb
of the light
but but it doesn't there's no spaceships
there's no nothing it's just a soap
opera based in Canton and you have you
know and it be and it begins you know
with you know
a man named Jane and then it then it's
off for the races
so so far like EastEnders but muddier
I actually think do you think I also a
Firefox from the stream now yeah a
firefly it leans back a little bit away
from the Western stuff in the adverts I
think that show would still be on the TV
now I think we'd have had 10 seasons in
that show I thought it was great well
the ad never did understand the
advertising you know it was like the
third episode was out before I okay fine
I'll go watch it they're like holy [ __ ]
this is good well that was a massive
Buffy fan I was really and I really like
Nathan Fillion even back then I really
like Nathan Fillion he was brilliant in
Buffy I watched two girls and guys in a
pizza place and he was my favorite
character in that towards the end of the
season so I knew the actor and thought
that would be great didn't know the rest
of the actors because nobody did but um
but I saw the advert for it and thought
well that looks stupid it was so silly
I'm not watching that [ __ ] and it was
only because after it was canceled ages
after they released the DVD box set of
like 12 episodes
um 16 episodes and it was 20 quid and I
was just like let's give it a go and I
loved it immediately
um
the advertising [ __ ] it yeah in in the
in and they released it out of order
and then they and they kept pausing it
for like um in America anyway didn't it
for um
baseball games and things
and it would be on the next week and
stuff and they say they [ __ ] it Fox
completely [ __ ] it yeah um
over here it was just on the Sci-Fi
channel which is like 250 something on
in on cable and you just nobody watched
it so but yeah
um but I loved it you know it's just
like but but Fox just completely ruined
it
but that didn't sound like you'd be
perfect to bring it back though
I love just hearing that because you
know Mando in general and then uh
uh Cowboys and Aliens is fun in general
as well and that's just a good one that
people forget about
and I think the thing is I mean it was
it was too character driven Nathan
Philly in his mouth was just too popular
they killed Alan tudick's character wash
they just killed him in the movie so and
he was so popular you know look at our
alien um resident alien how popular that
is and it's mostly because of Alan tudik
um you know Summer Glau is amazing
um uh uh the river characters they've
just got other than Simon nobody cared
about Simon
um but it was such a character-driven
show that they'd have to cast it
brilliantly because people are just
gonna hate it
they'll just automatically hate it and
that's the problem it's too loved
it's like if they try to bring back
Faulty Towers or something unless
somebody that's better than John Cleese
they're proud from Barcelona well yeah
but also you're gonna have to take a hit
on it because people are not going to
want to watch it straight it's just one
of those shows that you know it's really
hard to get right unless you get the
right character to come in and
well well you're you're kind of making
the point to do something new yeah
you're rebooting something you're
continuing something or whatever if you
start with something new
what is the fan base going to have to
[ __ ] about
yeah so something don't get me wrong
that the vocal gets saved tonight you
know they'll find something we always
find something we like to complain come
on
um I'm British it could be the nicest
day in the world to never sat there
going it's too nice
it's warm and it's lovely and I'm
[ __ ] I'm not at work today and I'm
bored
um and my tea is perfect yeah my cup of
tea is bloody lovely and I'm just like
yeah
it's it's
but we're that way I mean the internet
breeds that you know but um
I just I just think that yeah I'd love
to see I can't wait for that next big
thing that we've never heard of that's
new really capture us all and I think
the last time was
Game of Thrones
what was the last Avatar Avatar was 20
years ago
that's not a new one it's a sequel and
two weeks ago three weeks ago four weeks
ago
um what was the last big TV show then
that was like new we'd never heard of
that then went on to be like
uh I guess it would be games well TV
show that I mean you know like if you
remember when Game of Thrones started
you know there would be people that
would have interviewing parties
and they were just you know and they'd
dress up as the characters I mean it was
to the point that where
there was uh commercials
where people staged in you know a a
in one of these parties you know and
then somebody comes in dressed in as
like a character from Mad Men oh madman
was over last week you've got to be you
know Daenerys you know and that was
really a thing you know back then
however many years ago that was
and and but so if you look at that level
where it shapes culture that much I I
think we're
I have to say it's Game of Thrones that
was that was the last one that was that
impactful I think stranger things
possibly is the only one that is up up
there with it yeah I mean look at the
cycle house the the only show that did
do that after Game of Thrones was for
HBO Max as well but it only lasted for
one season before people were like all
right we're over with it was Westworld
Westworld out the season that first
season with Anthony Hopkins in every
episode was fantastic first off but that
got more views it had more people coming
back to the app and going back to uh HBO
in general yeah it was it was great for
him and then they released season two
but you know
season four was bad I always thought the
Westworld should have just been one
season for me
you know you make a movie like that you
do like 10 episodes and that's like
impact boom you know just like I
couldn't when they said they're doing a
second season I'm like how
you know it's just like you get these
shows sometimes it's just one season and
they should just impact I like the
second season
but the third just because it just takes
a nosedive the second season took a bit
of a nosedive where the third takes a
big nose dive and I haven't even tried
to watch the fourth I I actually still
haven't watched the peripheral yet I
know y'all both told me to but
not yet well I I struggle because
Westworld ended the way it did and I
still can't watch the fourth season I
need to by the time they take it off
because they're taking it off of HBO Max
but the the nail in the coffin that
makes me not even want to try the
peripheral or I want to but it it makes
it hard to try it out is as you all see
uh I don't know if it was Jonathan Nolan
as well but it was Lisa Joy you know his
wife who does all the stuff with him
did Joe watch reminiscence with he was
it Hugh Jackman and uh a long time ago
what's your name I saw in theaters when
it came out like the two two or three
years ago when it did
and that movie hurt that hurt me that
was bad it was it had a great concept
and just was not executed well and I I
haven't been able to go back into
Westworld since
great concept executed badly because
that's that's a whole stream all on our
own especially sci-fi yeah yeah yeah but
anyway guys look we've done an hour so
and it's Sunday and I did promise you
guys we would only stick to around an
hour
um and I don't need a week
after drinking Coke and stuff doing
these things
um but yeah
um
thank you so much again for for for
jumping on and and guys getting the con
this the comments this week have again
been amazing you've I'm they've been on
fire
um we've got the greatest we got the
greatest viewers we just really we do we
do and that that's that's a show I'm
actually genuinely looking forward to
the new Dean Devlin series with The Arc
um Matt has had a look and he's deep
dived on that he's doing a video on
Tuesday about the ark I believe I might
have
[Music]
um
that is done are you saying that the ark
is done by the Dean Devlin Dean Devlin
he's one of the co-creators so yes now I
gotta go get peacock damn
it yeah I know one thing after that it's
gonna be a Sci-Fi channel over here so
yeah
um
stormy and Harris thank you so so much
for getting up early on this Sunday
morning
um I'm just gonna do a quick promo for
nine Chevrons and then we'll say
goodbyes one sec nine chevrons.com
nine sharefronts.com is your dedicated
source for Stargate news which will aim
to complement this YouTube channel with
news that we have from our contacts at
MGM and Amazon breaking news about a new
potential Stargate series as well as
providing reviews and any potential
updates to new stories that we break
check out some of the news articles that
we have already at nineshavrons.com
nine chevrons.com you will you better
get there and also want to remind you
guys again we talked about a little bit
while Jamie was off I don't know with
his microphone the Discord server is
awesome get on the Minecraft world
great
all the links are in the description for
everything including sort of where we
sell a little bit of merchandise I
personally
the sleeping giant of sci-fi little
design I did is my is my happy place at
the moment I absolutely love it
um so
um yeah I really like that so
um I should be I should be a creator
um and let's not forget to mention uh
Harris's new line of CBD gummies
the buses
they were all over all over New York it
was just in about five of them there's
these bushes and they sit inside the
road and they're green and you can buy
peripherals and you can smoke a joint in
the back and it's like and they got
legalized thing all over them they're
everywhere
yeah okay so that that's not out in L.A
um but I I know Denver was thinking
about doing that a few years ago I had
no idea New York was doing it but that's
actually really fun they're like they're
essentially party buses but not
you know you know those fun little
things in like big cities where you get
a crew of people all around like a
bicycle and they're all pedaling and
drinking beers along the way it's kind
of like that but for for Stoners so
we're gonna sit down and someone else is
going to have to drive us but yeah all
good you know yeah at the end of the day
this is generally my um sort of my party
political forecast on ganja for a second
I drink we I drink weed I drink alcohol
it worked really well and then it'll
knock you out I like a nice cold chilled
weed in the morning it's
slip it in your Coke baby
um I I drink alcohol and occasionally
when I drink alcohol and I drink too
much I get really angry and
um and Shout at people and try to when
you go to soccer stadiums yeah and then
I go watch the my United win we won the
Derby yesterday come on United with dick
city
um and but you know like alcohol is
generally I I got a couple of buddies
that are police and they're just like
they're just like Friday nights just
like after God's sake it's just it's
just a nightmare for them
um teenagers like I'm drunk and really
big like no you're not sit up
um you know it's like but at the end of
the day
weed is way less um aggressive and bad
for your health all the things my only
issue is if you get up at breakfast or
um you know you're on your break at work
and you need to go and have a pint
you're an alcoholic if you need to go
and have a spliff you're a smokeaholic
or whatever the word is it's only
yeah right no no that's my only that's
my only issue with it so if I was
drinking with my breakfast I'd be
concerned
The Joint I feel or just ganja in in
general is just a little different just
because you can kind of smoke at any
time of day it depends what you're
smoking you got to know I mean there's a
lot of specificities my crazy self I'm
80d as can be if you can't see me I'm
looking around all the time you know
yada yada but I I refuse to take a pill
for it I never really have I don't like
Adderall Ritalin etc etc so I'll smoke
three to four times a day and that just
it calms me down chills me out I've said
this to you before about storm you run
Damien I used to the Mystery Machine
videos with you mentioned a couple of
times he I generally I've told him a few
times he self-medicates with weed and he
is a king you you would get on with him
lovely Harris you your your bedroom
smells similar I should imagine I've
never been in your bedroom but I've been
in Damian's a few times which is a
different story
um but you know it's like but he'll come
in and he's coming for work and he'll be
talking to me and he's like they're
talking to me we're like nose to nose
and I'm like dude for the love of God
God have a spliff and come back it goes
away I feel much better now gee look but
he's the same as anyone he's he's got
ADHD his brain just runs it a million
miles an hour it's like a Snickers
commercial you know it's just yeah yeah
one guy and you have a lot of Snickers
is like then you're a mellow I don't
know yeah it's the exactly though isn't
it that they I need to calm him down
calm down
um yeah I don't have an issue with that
I just got fun
a little skunky
but anyway thank you guys and um like I
say I've been emotional as always um
guys if you want to get the comments
there's anything you want us to talk
about next week is there any topics or
things you want us to focus on please
let us know we might even know something
a bit more about Stargate I'm really
hopeful that this week we might get
something actually solid so let's
fingers across everything I'm hearing
feels like it's coming to a yes or no
so let's
can't be much longer can't be much
longer yeah all right
um so let's hope that maybe we can tease
you with something next week so you'll
have to come back and join us next week
if they do so uh Jamie I did have one
last question concerning uh previous
episode we did uh on Avatar and its
budget yeah you know the they apparently
have met the budget they needed you know
they're that three billion dollar box
office not them
they needed 1.5 billion and they made
one they've made 1.7 before going into
this weekend yeah oh before this week
okay yeah I think that just crossed 1.8
there they think it'll it'll breach 2
billion
um but like I said that video I did
because I get I still got I got this guy
coming back going ah are you going to do
an apology video and I'm like no go back
and watch the original video again I've
got nothing to apologize for James
Cameron did an interview where he said
this film needs to make three billion
dollars to break even
all I did was go why are you saying that
that's a stupid thing to say don't say
it it would have to be twice as popular
as the most popular movie so far this
year and Maverick was just ridiculously
you know successful the most popular
movie of 2022 just if if
um Christmas had been pushed back two
weeks for some reason Avatar would have
overtook it
um but you know January first happened
when it did
um so all I was saying was why did James
Cameron say that it was a stupid thing
to say
um and it was a stupid thing to say
um for his word Avatar that had lost 1.2
billion dollars if you take him for his
word
which is not true
it was such a stupid thing to say
because how many how many uh I mean he
did I mean he shot footage for how many
of those uh films like the whilst
they're shooting currently uh episode
two third is already finished and I
think the fourth is upwards of like 80
to 90 done is what yeah I thought it was
the second is virtually done in the
third one filming was virtually done 89
done I don't even think they've started
on the fourth you mean third and wait
what we're talking about sorry the third
no you're right no sorry your Harris
you're right because I forgot about the
first one yes so because it was so long
ago that he finished the third film and
they are they have done a lot of
principal photography for the fourth
film you're right but also a lot of the
um a lot of the money apparently was
spent on just like creating the special
effects for this and creating the
programs for it which they're going to
use through all the films so it's like
they've spent it's a lot it's like
they've built the foundation for a house
that they want to build and the
foundation has cost them a shitload yeah
this house better be a mansion
you know if you you know watching the
movie then you see the actor perform he
had to take all the technology he had
for the first one and then convert it
for underwater and that takes a huge
engineering effort you know if you look
at it from that point of view because a
lot of it was shot underwater Oh yeah
and just the engineering stuff about it
I mean all the oh the one animal I can't
think of is you know the little smaller
water thing that they're always riding
around but that was legitimate water
jets like you'd see at a hotel or
something yeah yeah yeah go jump out of
water the fact that actors were on every
single intro of everything that we saw
in that movie is just it blows my mind
yeah well that was one of the things
they said wasn't one of the big expenses
very early on as well which is why again
the film massively run over budget
remember the budget for this film was
supposed to be 700 million dollars
didn't do that
um and seven can you imagine a budget of
700 million dollars
and they basically doubled it
um and then added through 400 million
dollars on for advertising a blah blah
so um yeah it took 1.8 billion this film
though is still it will have lost a lot
of money because you're remembering that
like the studio only gets about 40 of
that
so the studio is only actually getting
about eight or nine hundred million
dollars they've lost a lot of money so
have they actually lost a lot of money
though considering the third film has
already been filmed but that's the point
isn't it that that the money doesn't the
money hasn't really been spent on this
the next film will only maybe cost a
hundred million dollars and then it was
an additional cost yeah so right it's
not true
because a lot of the stuff that was
built for for the uh part two also
spills over to three four and five you
know so a lot of that budget for the
next film was already pre-loaded into
this film okay because I think there's a
big expense on you know like the motion
capture technology they use
um for the actors
um a lot of that was
that the best of that was probably done
for the Marvel movies with um Thanos and
stuff that was like and James Cameron
basically very early on said it's not
good enough it won't work what we've got
to do so we've got to basically reinvent
this technology and they had to they
went back to this
they went back to scrap one and then
covered here and they sort of apparently
I was watching I can't remember what I
was reading it they basically said we've
got time we may as well get it right
so they completely redid the software
for this technology and they did and
they basically created a new motion
capture technology for the Avatar movies
that won't have been cheap
um and but James Cameron was like well
we may as well do it right so let's do
it right I mean that's that's his
attitude is we could do Titanic just
with CGI and sets or we could just build
a two-thirds scale model and then split
the damn thing in half and you know like
the people actually didn't go you just
say we're going to build a Titanic yes
but an only small one yeah did he say we
could do it with sets
but we're gonna build a Titanic and it's
like that sorry but that's how Jennifer
Cameron thinks his life you're going to
do it do it right
who's got Loft your goals in that regard
James Cameron or Chris Nolan Mr I'm
gonna go build a freaking nuclear bomb
he didn't actually build a nuclear bomb
but right up next to it if they would
have given him a nuke he would have
blown it up you know
I think there are certain filmmakers
that genuinely they understand that CGI
and things will only get you so far
yeah I mean if you think about it but
in in
um
uh what was it the in the Deep one oh
what's it called weather underwater in
the summer yes the abyss how many times
you need to kill the actors told me it
was you that was telling us actually how
many times you nearly killed the actors
because even though he's got their
special he likes to do it as many
practical things as possible and even
though Avatar is like everything you see
on the screen is is is virtually all
computer generated yeah the Deep dive
suit was the risky thing in that
production yeah yeah
um but even though it's all CGI really
so much of it is based on practical
stuff I mean you've got actors there
doing the scenes and stuff when
the the animators must have been going I
really don't need them to do I can I can
just do it and then be like no no no
we're gonna do it properly
um and then the mouse won't look creepy
and [ __ ]
um like they're doing but yeah
so I get it but I just like saying I
understand but I had this guy really
preaching to me are you going to do an
apology letter because now it's gone by
1.8 billion either no watch the original
video again
an apology letter
are you gonna apologize to Mr Cameron I
don't think he cares
he's going to be getting a nice check
off from Warner Brothers they doesn't
care yeah he'll get several hell he's
still getting you know nice checks you
know from the Studios from you know
Terminator yeah he'll be okay he doesn't
need me to apologize
he'll be fine and I was again just
talking about his actual words that was
all I didn't make it up it's like
um but anyway but yeah so
um
so the next movie anyway is going to
make like a billion dollars easy
volcano Navi so intriguing and I will
say that you know the I went to go see a
young yesterday Adam matinee
sold out
still still
I'm looking at the box office right now
on Friday it made another 7 million
Saturday yesterday made 13.8 million and
this is all just U.S domestic today it's
projected to make another 10.3 and
tomorrow for MLK day they expect another
7.3 you can probably times that by 10.
yeah what it actually made that day
that's 30 million right there
they made 45 last weekend
our in UK Alone
um it's it's I think it's about a sixth
whatever they make in America will
you'll take over here okay for a big
block was to maybe about a sixth of that
which is weird because our population is
um our population is 70 million is it
300 million in the UK in the US sorry
closer to 400 in that 400 million
dollars next year I think something
so um so actually that works out doesn't
it as our population is about one-sixth
of yours and we take about one-sixth and
then you've got Europe and everybody's
you know it's like
so yeah
it's doing okay it's doing okay
next up is just gotta take Spider-Man no
way home out of its spot and I said
number six
it'll it'll be the second or third
highest gross movie of all time I think
it won't be Avatar though
oh I don't think so I think it's going
to be postcode go all the way there I
think it's gonna be fourth or fifth huh
yeah Avatar was just so over the top new
you know I mean it was everything it was
just no it was like uh I always saw
Avatar as you know as an analog when
Star Wars first came out no one had ever
seen anything like it
you know and then you know Cameron just
amped it up to 11 because no one had
seen anything like Avatar before
like our work in my generation it's
interesting yeah
oh by the way the U.S population uh for
this concerning uh up to 2021 was
331.9 million people exactly yeah 350
million yeah so about right I also asked
I was with 60 glass census was like 68
million yeah anyway we're we're still
better than America
um in most respects
most respects
how sport is the ice hockey is good
I watched the um the New York Rangers go
rangers
um and I'll tell you what that game
stopped every 30 to 40 seconds to like
and we've got somebody in the audience
that's kissing I'm like can we
concentrate the game please guys
right just one second as I have another
promotion thing that made them tells me
that's it all right Star Trek also has
some amazing merch get yours today and
show your support at side-track.com
um
but guys so right Stormy this the week
you beat
um 16 minutes out of me
[Laughter]
um 23 minutes over now so I'm very yeah
one one hour and six minutes we were
ready to end and I said goodbye to you
yeah we're at one hour 22 minutes the
only thing I got to do is you know this
is something that triggers you and we
are off to the races man so I figured oh
yeah let me do the thing about the
Avatar budget yeah yeah yeah yeah
we'll get him again
every damn week because I'm a jerk
but now I need to wait now he needs to
wee ladies and gentlemen
here's your son a 300 milliliter bladder
has reached capacity oh yes
um thank you again guys thank you so
much like I said get into the comments
guys tell us what you want to talk about
next week we will talk about 3D movies
or something at some point because we've
started that conversation and gimmicks
in cinema what the future Cinemas maybe
but let's have fun in the meantime guys
we will see you next Sunday
bye everybody
toodles they are totals
the British guy supposed to say toodles
you're supposed to say like
adios adios that's why we have the young
guy in USA to talk to the kids bye guys
all the kids these days are saying adios
well yeah it said it is California by
the way yeah watch Sidetrack tomorrow to
find out who the actor that's been set
up possibly for the new series is
because you're not gonna believe it I'm
not gonna believe it
um I'll give you a hint
um talk to me Goose see you later bye
bye
[Music]
[Music]